welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around
maybe i'll cut that last rant out
and uh post that post that on twitter
you guys can circulate that [ __ ] around
really [ __ ] [ __ ] these gqp or
siller cereal we have a we have a
birthday to celebrate um we have a hey
rachel how are you
happy happy [ __ ] birthday
man i gotta tell you this will be the
highlight of my birthday which is either
a backhanded compliment to you tony or a
sad testament to how sad my [ __ ] life
is
why i said you're in your pickup truck
right
i love i love when you join us in the
pickup truck yeah i do too in fact you
know i mean sometimes the nature of the
beast because i'm i'm like you know i
i'm basically i have a lot of jobs man
that's good well here i'll i'll make
your day uh caitlyn says happy birthday
rachel
um we have mj happy happy birthday
let's see if i can get my my mouse to
work here there he goes happy birthday
happy birthday happy birthday to you
happy birthday from lisa mayo says happy
birthday
tony and god i needed what you just
delivered
right into my veins so bad yeah well
that's great well tell me about that
because i think i think this is
important um with with
because it's the one of the most vile
things that i've actually seen these
[ __ ] idiots do when donald trump
stood on the stage and basically talked
about
vladimir putin
attacking ukraine uh with
which which there was no aggression from
ukraine murdering women and children
bombing apartment buildings residential
areas um he's going to do a lot of
killing a lot of damage to that country
all just to bang up democracy and here
these people are eating salmon eating
their salad drinking their wine
thousands of dollars they paid for this
fundraiser for this plate it says maga
behind the [ __ ] it says make
america great again behind him oh [ __ ]
none of a [ __ ] is talking about how oh
two dollars worth of sanctions what a
great deal for putin
no [ __ ] dude why can't we get that
messaging and figure out how to make
sure that these [ __ ] are tied to that
we talk about the balls right now tony
yeah we've got him by the balls right
now and there's no [ __ ] doubt about
it and you know here's the motive i mean
there's two reasons to do that number
one i mean for the
the uh
importance of making sure the electorate
knows what they're voting for in the
fall but also this i mean here's the
thing this situation in russia as you
were alluding to uh with your little
tour of world history this is some
complex [ __ ] and i always knew that was
complex but now that i've taken this
deep dive into world civ let me tell you
like this is this is a messy [ __ ]
situation with putin because there's no
doubt that he's taking ukraine because
he understands what the nuclear arsenal
that he has
nobody can really stand up to him other
than the ukrainians but you know let's
look down the road a bit i mean it's so
much like the sudetenland and the
beginnings of the rise of the hitler
regime in terms of its military
dominance um very very similar
circumstances and i think anybody would
be a fool to think putin isn't
interested in additional countries
especially within that nato circle so
you know this idea that we have to fight
our enemy now i mean this will be the
first time america's faced a major
conflict in which we have a domestic
[ __ ] enemy and that domestic enemy is
half of one of our major political
parties and so yeah we need to be coming
down on them hard we gotta make make it
absolutely [ __ ] painful for them to
cow tail and uh you know do propaganda
for this [ __ ] dictator so i'm really
happy to hear you um highlighting it and
really making the case
well i think it's important and uh gabe
does too gabe's joining us here
let me uh let me uh
get get gabe in here because i know he
probably has some questions for you as
well hi gabe
hey course of course gabe always
always with the microphone oh yeah yeah
i'm just trying to be respectful while
i'm in the green room you know i'm
hanging out having snacks being quiet
okay
do you have any questions uh for rachel
because i i know we always talk about
the messaging and and rachel we did a
whole show yesterday we watched video we
talked about the murders dictator putin
um continuously but gabe did you have
anything you wanted to ask rachel
uh
i mean i think the biggest thing i think
that is that on everyone's minds is like
the
you know i think there's the potential
and obviously like the hope that that
the united front of both protesting
russians and those with that are in
ukraine as these ukrainian people also
there's that you know i think you did
you just play the the clip of the
fighter jet that i sent you this morning
yeah the the ghost of kiev which is
really [ __ ] cool
that is the hardest badass name i've
ever heard
right yeah i'm just [ __ ]
[ __ ] anyway
yeah no i look at that and i see this as
like an opportunity like if you know if
if putin as deranged delusional and
paranoid as he is like this i guess it's
not so much a question as an observation
it's like
there's a you know there is the
potential that
the normal average human both russian
and ukrainian has the opportunity to
stand up against a dictator
and a tyrant and actually defeat him
um you know and it's it's actually
very powerful to see right like because
you see this guy coming late at night
russians wake up to the to the news that
oh [ __ ]
we're at war now
and
it's especially something that they
didn't ask for and now we're seeing that
there's actually like a
a solid front you know people that are
even you know volunteering to deploy and
find their own way into ukraine to to
uh that aren't even russian or ukrainian
but just like normal canadian american
civilians that want to come in and help
um you know and aid them so
yeah i suppose i'm really lucky i'm not
healthy you know and young and
urge dude i want to go over there and
defend them too it is so frustrating
understanding the geopolitical danger
that we're in with the nuclear
situation right so like i mean putin
knows he's got the world by its balls in
this in this endeavor and it is because
you know at the end of the day ukraine
once had russia's you know the soviet
union had its own arsenal and we
the world's like hey we'll take care of
you don't worry
[ __ ] dude you know so like the nuclear
non-proliferation effects of this are
just so extreme but
here's the thing with putin do i think
he's i don't do i think he would
actually go and launch a nuke no i don't
i don't think so
um but i don't i i think the
complication of nuclear
fallout you know not literal fallout but
like the potential for a nuclear
engagement i mean it's just got
all of our nato not just us you know you
can only negotiate or
you know aggressively respond so far
without risking geothermal nuclear war
and that's why i think the pressure
really ought to be put on china right
because here's china's choice do you
want to be in the new world or the old
[ __ ] world make them choose
right um right now what emboldens russia
is that knowledge of having access to
chinese currency chinese markets i mean
it's a big [ __ ] economy and at the
end of the day like the most effective
thing that we could possibly do in this
situation is to is to force china to
walk away from supporting this uh
endeavor by russia even if you know it's
really not reasonable to expect them to
do anything other than that but you know
china's got it we got to push china on
this i think
yeah i think that
well i was gonna say you know that's a
that's a good point because um
we've already seen that the gqp uh
tucker carlson and others have started
to backtrack you know you're saying
china to backtrack we've already seen
just just in the messaging here they've
realized that oh wait a second he was
actually serious as a murderous dictator
this wasn't just a [ __ ] game like it
wasn't just a [ __ ] game and i think
it's a good observation that not only
china but everyone else who's [ __ ]
decided they're gonna put in with putin
really better start to decide where
they're going to put it right and that's
and that's what i'm trying to convey
about that that goddamn whatever
fundraiser that was that that piece of
[ __ ] was at
talking into the microphone acting like
ukraine was some kind of real estate
deal that no [ __ ]
but the people sitting there just having
a great day with the steak and the
salmon and it was all fine and good and
and those people need to really start to
wake up and understand that
your next you're next on his list i
don't know i just think that's a
messaging what are you doing i didn't
mean to interrupt you
history is very clear about who who
comes next okay so like i mean here's
the thing all you all you putin enablers
out there that can hear my voice should
understand that if you ever get your
[ __ ] wish you will hate the world you
live in like the wife in in the
handmaid's tale that comes to regret her
life decisions that put her in a
subservient
anti-freedom place that chops her finger
off for [ __ ] reading okay tucker you
don't want to live there buddy and um
you know yeah you won't have to look at
gay people because they imprison them
and murder them in russia is that what
your ambition is for gay people here in
america i think inquiring minds like
mine would like to know
i i think that's a great point and i
think that's why why we need to hold
these [ __ ] to the fire and i and i
don't just mean the elected officials
all of them and we need to keep we need
to keep giving the airways to these
morons saying the stupid [ __ ] everyone's
like oh don't give tucker attention when
he's cow cowing to putin [ __ ] do not
look away don't look away
because i gotta tell you what we're
doing here tony and gabe and the
audience too and anybody who's listening
to us you know
this is this is not a [ __ ] game
all right even if you think the election
[ __ ] and you know staving off fascism
and blah blah blah is a game which i do
not even if you think that what's going
on here is if we do not cow-tail the
radical element of the republican party
and obliterate them on this particular
issue and quickly we may lose this
geopolitical battle to [ __ ] russia
okay you don't want to do that so we
really really really got to put pressure
on them for national security interest
as well as political interest i think
well gabe we we uh we we looked at a
letter yesterday about uh from general
michael flynn and there was something
that you tweeted uh
tell tell rachel that the part in the
letter that really pissed you off
oh the uh he goes through and then it's
at the final it's the butt right the
butt and which is which very much
reminds me of these like with that being
said you know it totally negates what
was just said right like you know you
may have an issue with what was done you
don't support the invasion the killing
is people but then if you have a but
this is what happens when you do x y or
z no shut the [ __ ] up you are now
negating everything that just came
before it so obviously your position is
that you do support putin and you do
want this to be in the position that
it's in and everything that you've put
in this letter is completely just like
moot it doesn't matter because we know
what your actual position is your
opinion is and how you feel about the
situation so don't come in with this
here's my official letterhead and my
signature and all this [ __ ] because
what you actually want is what is
happening
yeah yeah yeah and people like flynn and
tucker carlson especially carlson with
that big ass megaphone he has autumn
considering what they can do for this
country right now right and what they
should not be doing is using their giant
[ __ ] multi-million viewer megaphone
to aid and abate our enemy and you know
to me that's trader behavior right and
uh tuck i don't think you want to be a
traitor dude
i mean just the idea that tucker would
go on the air and then say you know
you know using the the personal
anecdotes to be like has tucker ever
done this to you has tucker ever done or
sorry has well tucker has done all that
right right right right tucker's
probably eating dog too you know uh but
it for putin it's like oh has put never
done this has put never done this to you
you know like charlotte is like well i
guess he's never done this to me
personally
but that type of narrative that type of
specific
the the the choice in words yes are very
deliberate and used to say well he's
never done anything to me personally so
i don't have a problem with them and
that type of narrative begins to shift
so that you say like well
i guess he's not so bad right he hasn't
attacked me personally so i don't have
any qualms with him
again just ignoring the fact of
poisoning journalists imprisoning people
killing people for the for being who
they are you know sexually you know
whatever like it doesn't matter the
point being like this guy is a you know
a wannabe dictator tyrant and his time
is coming to an end and we're seeing
that from the people who are standing up
against him who mind you these people
are risking their lives and i was
watching videos outside of you know i
saw some stuff from vice where they were
getting literally pulled away from cops
they're just protesting and saying no
war right that's the world that they
live in and that you know putin wants
which is anybody who speaks out against
me
done you're either silent or you're in
support
yeah and and it's worse than that gabe
because like that checklist that tuck
rolled out on his show about what putin
doesn't do to him okay when you think
about what it's collective message
because like it starts off with some
like pretty specific things and then it
gets into policy right he's like oh well
over there in russia i don't have to
have a boy playing on my girl's soccer
team right so it's not j he's aspiring
to a civilization that putin is creating
because along these culture war issues
okay
which which is so [ __ ] stupid because
it absolutely absolutely discards or
disregards the fact that in russia
tucker carlson doesn't exist dude
there's no [ __ ] tucker carlson right
and if he tried to even say one thing
about putin his ass would be you know in
one of these russian prison camps dude
so like oh it's just so crazy to me that
these men
have decided to aspire to an autocracy
just because they think and they they
only think about how it will benefit
them and then at the end of the day if
they ever got their wish and we started
down that slope and we move into one
party rule in this country what history
tells us is all these enablers
all get [ __ ] killed jailed whatever
right
in the end so yeah we go first like all
the opponents of the opposition the
marginalized groups but at the end of
the day the butcher comes all the way
home to the hog
well you you damn right
can you can you imagine
in vladimir putin's russia
if he required people to get vaccines to
go get a whopper from burger king and
they protest out in front of the burger
king can you imagine can you oh i got
arrested for
you know because i was a nuisance and i
got released with a fine and can you
imagine can you imagine the same
[ __ ] when they would be
treaded off to a camp because they were
just not not the sense of the mandates
you're a descent of the leader you're no
[ __ ] yeah they don't understand when
you're when you're protesting and when
you're causing a ruckus and you're
breaking you know laws in a town where
you're causing a disruption in a
restaurant right on private property and
you're arrested that's not the same
that's not the same as what putin would
do to you tony i gotta tell you too man
i mean and i'm not a concern i've never
been a republican i've never been a
conservative dude but i understand and
have studied all of the ideologies and
the intellectual philosophical
underpinnings of the ideologies and
there is nothing more antithesis to
intellectual conservatism than what that
[ __ ] that that that that
anti-american
prophet kgb latin [ __ ] propaganda
coming out of fox news a major american
news station okay uh the the fact that
he lives in a country that is so [ __ ]
free it's letting him run russian kgb
propaganda out of one of the most you
know populated news audiences
totally [ __ ] lost on them you know
well i i think i think they're totally
lost on a lot of things yeah um you know
we we have an interview of course we've
had this russian news that we've been
we've been trying to play this interview
it's almost two hours um that we've got
um with an interview of someone who's
went through the data of the uh the
gibson go on the ottawa truckers thing
and it's it's not what it appeared to be
right it wasn't about vaccines right
that's not what it was it's about
anti-democracy and if you look at the
data you start to get suspicious about
what what possible motives could happen
with the transactions that happened on
this gibson go like where's the money
coming from you know all these things
was it a test run for something you know
you get all these questions that start
to happen and i hope to play that
interview on monday or tuesday but don't
you think that not not just january 6
but we've had many events that look like
it we've had all these nazi rallies that
they've had because a former president
united states doesn't go around doing
rallies that's not running for president
that's not a thing that happens it's not
a thing that happens right no
it's not not in a democracy you lost you
lost you lost you can run again and then
you can try to rally and win again go
build a library or something like that
right right well
the problem is the real the the problem
is with the trump library it's going to
be more like a coloring book factory
yeah library like it's like a like maybe
a coloring book factory slash like
outhouse you know right right really fun
fact about trump well i'm on board i
found this out actually from like a
student that is was involved in one of
his works and so had gone down to mar
largo and i think enough times passed
now no one will be able to identify the
students so anyway she was telling me
down in mar-a-lago in the kitchens they
have every kind of fast food burger
right that you could ever want and it's
all set up in this like microwave system
with all the like the specific heating
instructions from each of the chains
provided to people
you know
i've been able to independently verify
this but it sounds so [ __ ] on point
but uh you know who knows but yeah i
figured you'd enjoy that i don't know
yeah
you remember what what what sports team
was it it was in the white house and he
was like oh we're not going to serve him
food we're going to get a mcdonald's or
something wasn't it it was uh it was it
was nc nc double a basketball right yes
the conversation actually now that you
mention it because i i mentioned that in
class and that's when the story got
relayed to me i was like oh god that's
so [ __ ] because you know he's got a
fast food addiction right
like
like literally his own [ __ ] little
like restaurant down there like with all
of his faves from whichever burger king
and mcdonald's and [ __ ]
well you know you know i actually
encourage donald trump to eat at least
four big macs a day
large fries kfc eat a whole bucket of
chicken you fat [ __ ] no nothing nothing
says into fascism like a little bit of
heart disease that's all i'm saying yeah
i'm not rich and ill upon anyone i'm
just you want to accelerate it a bit i
mean i don't know if you guys remember
this but after the after he lost the
election the like the first or second
time uh he was
he was gorging he was eating all of the
hamburgers and all the fast food and it
was so bad that there were reports
coming out that aids had to like [ __ ]
spritz down the place and light candles
and make sure it didn't smell because he
would it just smelled like it was just
like like like birdies and hearts or
what yeah it was it was just like the i
think the official word was flatulence
but it was just it was soaking in like i
i swear the person whoever flips the
white house to get ready for the next
presidency was like steam wall in the
[ __ ]
ripping down
so you had to flip the cushions on the
sofa yeah they're like listen we
normally put this in storage but we're
gonna have to burn this [ __ ]
here's the thing though let me interrupt
real quick because i think this
this means we gotta we've gotta ask our
friend at patriot takes who seems like
to get some [ __ ] some good [ __ ] out of
mar-a-lago in terms of photos right go
get us a photo of that [ __ ]
kitchen dude i want to see that supply
change
right yeah yeah well you know that's
that i i i again
i've had you know experience with fast
food farts flatulence as as gabe calls
it yeah i can't imagine the amount of
food that this guy eats as fat [ __ ]
seeks uh speaking of that
going back to how to tie this in to the
little video that he had um his little
nazi video where he's talking about how
great it is that russia and putin has
made this big real estate deal uh
you know basically [ __ ] all over the
people who are dying in ukraine that are
being killed and
what's funny at the very end of that
clip
he says and i want to thank ronnie
jackson do you guys know who ronnie
jackson is remember right now he's the
one that stood on stage and debased
himself and said
donald trump is the healthiest human
being i've ever he weighs 102 pounds
i'd be like
tony i mean come on dude i mean you can
see that it's not like it's [ __ ]
invisible
so much you know
i just i can't understand how how uh
ronnie jackson as a doctor would debase
himself but but the greatest part is is
when he's standing in that room when
he's standing in that room that's the
one person the one person that he picks
out that called him thin that called him
the healthiest person in the world
let one person out in that moment and
and and and he's ronnie jackson stands
up and that's where everything's running
where's ronnie where's my where's my
little ronnie come on right here right
like that's what he is right and that
guy has
sold his soul for he will forever be you
know indebted to him and i'm sure he's
got something on him and i i just like
also no one else is gonna [ __ ]
respect that guy to be like yeah this
guy's bmi was totally within the normal
range
he totally passed that cognitive test
like all of these things where you're
like i highly doubt your professional
and medical opinion right now because it
needs dog [ __ ] at this point
yeah
that's what i i mean you guys are going
to see this
coming up in an interview that will
release soon i'm like you know
the problem is once you deliver me a
bunch of [ __ ] like then everything
else you say is like meaningless right
so you know that's one reason why to
live in reality land where you know
things are actually true because once
you're full of [ __ ] about one thing all
right and so ronnie jackson my guess
here too guys and i don't know this for
a fact but i know that it's true is a
pill slinger right and that's probably
why
he had to go out there and debase
himself but i don't know if you guys
remember he got kicked out of the white
house or slinging opioids to the staff
or you know off prescription that's just
kind of a little legal yeah well i mean
i'm sure yeah like you said i'm sure
that behavior was not new to his tenure
at the white house it was probably
before that as well and of course was
like well is the only job i can get
these days so [ __ ] i'm all in you
know not anymore now he's running for
office as a republican
oh
isn't that fantastic so so i mean i mean
that's that's the other thing i want to
talk about before we go here is that
this putin thing this this this putin
infatuation that these idiots like mike
flynn have been perpetuating to get
their followers to get on the side of
authoritarianism because that's really
what it is they're trying to push their
followers to be more authoritarian
because that serves their purpose but
how do we in in in a race against ronnie
jackson how do we how do we say hello
wake up what's the messaging that we use
in this country to make sure people know
oh the putin thing that's one thing
that's going to happen to you what what
do we do about the messaging because i
know the strategic outrage is always
um you're right up your alley to make
sure that the messaging's on point so
how do we tie
not just mike flynn but how do we make
all the gqp mike flynn a a a putin
capitulator how do we do that it's not
hard at all guys i mean and they've
really
served us up an unfortunate circumstance
where i mean
not insignificant and chill i mean the
party is deeply divided on this issue
right now
and luckily
luckily figuring out that actually in
some of the most important states in
2022 there are significant populations
of white ukrainians that they need to
vote for them right so like you know i
only mention that because they're never
going to do anything for the good of
america they need a
a motivation so let's hope that that
kind of cow tales some of this effort
but the fact of the matter is public
opinion flows from the top down
republicans have invented a system based
on joseph gobel's system in in nazi
germany to control information flow and
create a media ecosystem that they
control and they've done that in 20
something years right now and on that
media ecosystem if you're seeing you
know even 30 of the programming trying
to to not only normalize
authoritarianism autocracy and in the
case of
putin i would say totalitarianism you
are trying to sell it you're he's
they're selling the vision imagine this
white audience of mine i'm tucker
carlson here obviously imagine this
utopia where there's no gay people in
your face and you know da da da da and
like they you know they so what my point
is
is that this is so easy to explain to
people this is not a challenge at all
freedom democracy autocracy and
dictatorship right and you just have to
make sure that when you're doing that
people can see themselves in that
calculus and it's not just about people
elsewhere so it's really important that
we um always condition our advertising
in what i call that me frame and not the
we collective because unfortunately for
us like we're the we people and we're
just not a very big chunk of the
electorate
you know uh someone the other day
tweeted
a an acronym for g.o.p and i think it
was i think it was someone maybe i know
it was grand old putin
yeah
g.o.p
old putin so i mean i think i think
that's an easy way to do it i mean maybe
not in the exact words but to say look
the gqp is the party of putin
there it is and what we do what we do is
we drive wedges because i think they
they are ultimately divided on this
issue for obvious reasons and we should
drive wedges in those obvious reasons
right and drive wedges in between them
and break up their electorate in some of
these districts i think it is possible
that they're
vulnerable dude
they were already vulnerable because of
ron johnson and if i was able to run the
whole country strategy right uh they
were already hella vulnerable all three
of those midwestern states exactly for
these demographics that i was just
talking about and because ron johnson is
literally like you're a quintessential
tucker carlson in elected office right
he is just as bad says just as terrible
[ __ ] and is just as busy trying to sell
people in the vision of living in an
autocracy right but now it's not even
abstract now it's it is all you know a
big chunk of the party it is a
definitional moment for republicans and
it there is a huge value in going in
there and hitting their own
you know electorate in a targeted way on
this issue and making that choice very
clear
america versus putin right are you on
team america and you know team america
is not the republicans right now or are
you with putin and the republican party
and i think i think we can drive wedges
in in those areas between the uh
republican electorate and the
conservative the gop electorate the
trump electorate we really can draw
those stark issues now rather it's now
rather it's those people go and vote for
a pro-democracy candidate which right
now as we see in this country there's
only one party that stands behind
democracy
here's the thing you know that gabe
knows that the audience knows that
twitter knows that and but the idea that
out there and i'm luckily in my truck so
i can look out in the world out there
everybody knows that not unless we
[ __ ] tell them we have to tell them
that
well and we got to do it over and over
and over and over again because that
works it works to repeat these messages
and pound it in brains and
where to where people are tired of it
because because i think i think you
tweeted something um last week or the
week before about tom brady's uh
retirement and deflated football like
literally more people know the
circumstances around tom brady retiring
then what it means to have fascists
like putin to take over our country and
what it means for football like you
wouldn't have the nfl
that thing would not exist in the way
that it exists they would get rid of the
majority of people who play in the nfl
yeah no [ __ ] dude like that's what they
would do
it just it baffles me every single time
that we that that it it's so hard to
convince these people that hey you're
say you're for freedom and liberty but
ultimately you don't know what it is and
it's obvious that you don't because
you're you're thinking that the freedom
to oppress the rights of other people is
liberty and it's not yeah
you do not get to
freely oppress the rights of other
people that's not liberty that is the
opposite of liberty and you need to come
to the side of actual liberty and know
that equality and equity is gonna
deliver it to you yeah and in case any
actual conservatives ever [ __ ] listen
to this i'm gonna just say and that's
the opposite of natural law too right i
mean it's a perversion of the idea of
natural law because a lot of the um
philosophical basis for individualism
like hyper individualism that i would
call now because it used to be rugged
individualism now with the gop what
people with certain elements of the gop
are
propositioning is hyper right it's a
hyper version of that and so you know we
really just need people to understand
autocracy versus democracy in 2022. one
party's for democracy one party's for
autocracy and that is an easy message
now because um
putin's the kind of uh story that
everyone knows you know what i mean so
like in uh the american conscious it's
not gonna be hard for people to to see
what's happening in ukraine in a way
that affects them here
and i i think that's correct and i think
that's why you see a lot of even tucker
carlson trying to back away from his
statements the gt and we should not let
them back away we should make them
answer for those statements because i
believe that's partly why putin
is braving what he's doing no yeah no
you know this is all part of his
strategy right so like so important i
mean i always talk about how oh here we
are in 22 and we're in this republican
playbook that's been ongoing now for
about 25 30 years it's been edited a few
times updated changed but it's a
strategic [ __ ] plan and it has like
five-year 10-year goals and now we're
sitting in there like their 20-year goal
on media and you know 10-year goal and
digital 10-year goal and electoral
reform so you know putin's plan was
destabilize the west around the issues
of racial grievance help do that because
it's already there and i can amplify
that
gets more than he could have ever
[ __ ] hoped for because his dumb [ __ ]
celebrity
corrupt criminal manages to win the
nomination and the general election and
becomes president of the united states
and for four years putin has sowed the
seeds of division here domestically
because at the end of the [ __ ] day
guys if we can't get tucker carlson to
shut the [ __ ] up what's gonna happen is
we're not gonna see a rally around the
flag effect for the first time in
american [ __ ] history we're not gonna
see the population rally around the flag
after pearl harbor okay some you know
i'm not talking about like way you know
with war in world war ii i'm talking
about after being actively you know
engaged in it so we really have to put
pressure on them for more than politics
is literally depending on the state of
of the world to keep these people from
turning half the republican party into a
machine
well i do appreciate you coming on as
always you are always welcome back
hopefully we can get you on next week we
can find i i know we had trouble with
your schedule this week i know there's
some some good things coming because of
that so i'm excited um and also
gabe did you did you know that it's
someone's birthday did you know that i
saw i saw in the comments i wanted to
wait for like asylum so i could say
happy birthday yeah so so everyone
everyone thanks for wishing
rachel happy happy happy birthday and we
are so happy to have you on during your
birthday it's my privilege man getting
to hang out my few favorite boys like
this on my birthday i love it so thanks
guys hope you have a good day we will
see you soon and everyone stick around
we're going to do bonehead of the week
right after the break stick around
we'll be right back
mark
66